we begin this half-hour with a dilemma
for one Washington couple as they
followed through with their long planned
wedding how could guess honor their
Union while still honoring the
restrictions meant to keep us safe in a
pandemic as Christina Ruffini reports
like many of us these days they used a
little creativity and found a way Sara
and Marco Sylvester didn't plan to have
their first dance on a street corner
[Music]
they also didn't plan to get married on
a Tuesday in a mostly empty Church but
life and coronavirus happen prepared for
marriage we're ready for marriage
and we plan to get married we decided
that under no circumstances would we
postpone so 48 hours before DC went on
lockdown Sara made a call they called me
I was like hey we're gonna elope Travis
Gardner was supposed to play at the
reception but Sara asked if there was
any way he could get to the church like
I'm doing this for Marco she's like so
you can't tell him it's a surprise the
song's lyrics wise men say Only Fools
Rush In struck a chord with the couple
when early on friends questioned their
whirlwind romance but even the skeptics
cheered when they tied the knot live
over Instagram
as they left the church a procession
drove by to wish them well then of
course it started raining but Gardner
played on that felt like it was in a
movie and then I looked at her and she
was just sobbing so then I made sure to
grab her and start dancing with her that
was just the most beautiful special
experience and wouldn't have had it any
other way
[Music]
right now the world just need love
everybody love and come together we can
beat anything love and happy fools who
get married even in the rain for CBS
this morning Saturday
Christina Ruffini Washington who knew
it's from bone could bring such
happiness from bone showed II gave him a
run for his money
so damn teary-eyed as a newlywed watchin
that amazing just amazing